est-ce que je suis sûr d'avoir envie
d'avoir dieu tatoué sur les fils moi je
suis sûr [__] c'est quoi ça longtemps
l'apanage des marginaux et des
prisonniers le tatouage est devenu un
accessoire de mode aussi courants que
les accessoires de mode les plus
courants d'ailleurs je suis persuadé que
plus de la moitié d'entre vous qui me
regardait et déjà tatoué ou envisagent
de le faire
mais est-ce que vous êtes déjà demandé
ce qui se passe dans votre corps quand
vous faites appliquer ce qu'on attend
parce qu'on ne parle bien que de ce
qu'on connaît vraiment pour ce sujet
j'ai décidé de donner de ma personne et
notamment de mon fessier puisque c'est à
cet endroit que je vais me faire tatouer
le visage de ses douze anges partie côté
allez on file au salon de tatouage donc
on a un studio 23 cas l'air je vais
confier mon fessier à julien et hama et
je vais aussi leur confier mon modèle
pour qu'il le tattoo dessus
est-ce que je suis sûr d'avoir envie
d'avoir dieu tatoué sur le cul moi je
suis sûr et on y va
[Musique]
le tatouage c'est ni plus ni moins que
des injections d'encre sous la peau donc
avant d'aller vous faire tatouer
idéalement préparé la zone en prenant
soin de votre peau pour qu'elle soit
propre saine et hydrater le jour j pour
le reste le tatouage s'occupe de tout là
par exemple il est en train de me raser
le cul pour était que les poils se
coince dans la plaie et que s'infecte
comme avant une opération pareille alors
en plus apprécié bien parce que c'est
tout doux fait ensuite un petit coup
d'antiseptiques et le tatoueur que
posait le talk avec le modèle et après
c'est parti
[Musique]
allez on y va bien c'est quand tu veux
ça bermo graf c'est un moteur qui a
actionné par une [__] et qu'entraîne
l'éguille où les aiguilles qui injecte
clank 1 à 4 millimètres sous la peau
grâce à un mouvement de va-et-vient
super rapide c'est parti alors la peau
ces trois couches l'épiderme à la
surface puis le derme et en dessous
l'hypoderme en le tatoueur il envoie
lancre au niveau du berne et à part pas
avec la peau morte parce que c'est les
cellules de l'épiderme sont renouvelées
régulièrement
bon je vous laisse parce que ça sent un
peu fort et si en plus les cellules qui
sont chargés de faire le ménage dans le
béarn qu'on appelle des macrophages
elle n'arrive pas à évacuer les pigments
de lancre parce qu'ils sont trop fade
pour elle
du coup lancre elle reste sur place et
est fini par être absorbé par d'autres
cellules qu'on appelle des fibroblastes
et qui garde la couleur sur place sans
bouger ça picote 1-2 picotte alors petit
conseil d'ami
ne buvez pas d'alcool avant une séance
de tatouage ça perturbe la coagulation
en faisant baisser le taux de plaquettes
dans le sens du coup ça va saigner
franchement ce faire un truc bourré bof
la sopic un peu plus la statue soit
partout pareil on va pas se mentir ça
pique un peu pour choisir l'endroit où
voulez-vous faire le vôtre vous que en
gros plus la peau in fine - yade cher -
jan hus plus on est au contact direct de
los plus ça fait mal
franchement la fesse ça va on avant de
choisir quand on fait aussi au grain de
beauté
si vous en avez sur la zone que vous
voulez vous faire tatouer montrer les un
dermato avant si vous avez tendance à
avoir des cicatrices en relief qu'on
appelle des chéloïdes c'est peut-être
pas une bonne idée de se faire connaître
au rayon des contre indications au
tatouage on peut noter tout ce qui est
en lien avec le risque d'infection à
savoir si on est enceinte
bon moi je vais vérifier second si on
est soi-même porteur d'un germe ou d'un
virus comme les batiks par exemple ou si
votre système immunitaire est affaibli
par le sida par exemple
les problèmes de coagulation comme
l'hémophilie ou certains médicaments
c'est aussi une contre indication et si
vous souffrez d'une maladie comme une
insuffisance rénale ou cardiaque ou du
diabète
parlez-en à votre médecin avant d'aller
vous faire peut-être alors dernière
contre indication dans l'absolu avoir
des goûts de merde
bon c'est un peu subjectif à et si vous
avez des allergies parlez-en à votre
médecin avant aussi parce que des
allergies à l'encré ça existe enfin à
certains composants de lancre ya
d'ailleurs des règles très strictes
française et européenne sur la
composition des produits sur l'hygiène
aussi parce qu'on parle quand même d'une
injection avec dutronc et tout donc tout
doit être propre voire stérile voire
stérile et à usage unique
ah oui et à thouaré doit porter des
gants assez important l'hygiène un mois
là je suis en toute confiance nous vous
choisissez bien mais des liens dans la
description de vous aider si vous
respectez tous ces conseils
pas de problème en plus selon une étude
publiée en mars 2016 dans l'american
journal of human biology les personnes
les plus tatoué loin meilleur système
immunitaire bah voyons cette merveille
une fois que j'ai franchi le pas suivez
bien les conseils de votre tatoueur en
termes de soins du tatouage en gros
lavez le à l'eau et au savon au ph
neutre et mettez de la pommade
cicatrisante franchement ah oui et
surtout éviter d'exposer votre tatouage
au soleil pendant environ six semaines
bon - vu l'endroit ça devrait aller ah
oui l'eau de mer bateau
alors voyons ça [__] c'est quoi ça non
mais je vous ai donné quoi comme descend
puis transfère descendre mon petit frère
jeu ça partira jamais dit ça s'enlève
mais bon c'est pas simple déjà pour
commencer il faut attendre deux mois
entre le tatouage et le détatouage donc
on se retrouve dans deux mois pour la
suite bon alors il y aura d'autres
vidéos avant un bien sûr donc le petit
abonnement qui va bien pour être sûrs de
rien rater et pour cette nouvelle année
alors qu'est ce que je peux vous
souhaitez mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]